the United States Pizza restaurant
industry cooked up forty four billion
dollars in sales last year but Wall
Street is focused on the nation's number
two chain since early 2010 the stock
price of Domino's Pizza has soared from
listen to this
nearly $15 a share to about a hundred
and ninety seven dollars today now that
is a thirteen hundred thirty three
percent increase Domino's operates more
than fourteen thousand stores worldwide
it delivers more than a million pizzas a
day
the chains busiest delivery day his New
Year's Eve Domino's president and CEO
Patrick Doyle is credited with
reinvigorating the brand he joins us now
welcome thank you I've been very very
good to you so question is you have said
this is a brand in progress yes what did
you need well you know we're always
looking for ways we can improve and so
we just look at it and say you know we
haven't gotten there we haven't figured
everything out we wake up every morning
and see the problems in our business and
then we go after fixing them you know
it's interesting you say that because
President Obama spoke here yesterday to
Bill Gates thing that we were referring
to and sort of the central thing he said
he was constantly trying to say who is
dad we can do better we can do better
how do we do better that's exactly right
and so that's what we're doing so you
know we look at the that the food we had
to get the pizza right and we did that
right at the beginning of 2010 and that
really started the momentum and then we
looked at the ordering process and said
that's not working very well we got to
bring digital into that get that better
we're just constantly looking at how can
we improve the experience for somebody
today and make it better than it was a
year ago and if we do that we're gonna
grow the business and you think
driverless cars Patrick will improve
that we do we do a absolutely do so
we're now testing a vehicle we've got a
partnership with Ford Roush did the
build-out down in southeast Michigan
right we're in the center of the
automotive industry in the mobility
industry in Michigan and we look at it
and say look the transportation is going
to change dramatically over the next ten
years a lot of people have been focused
on how you're going to use self-driving
vehicles to move people around we looked
at it and and got in contact with
warden said look you know if if we are
looking out five years we are clearly
going to be seeing differences in how
we're going to be delivering pizzas
we've got to start working on this and
so for us we're testing the last 50 feet
will people come out of their apartments
and out of their home do you want people
in their pajamas going out to the car
it's either it's either coming out to
the car or at their door have you been
in a driverless car yourself I have
tried it I have I did three four years
ago I was an expressway doing 70 miles
an hour and in two minutes I felt
completely comfortable there was an
engineer while the car was driving along
the highway at 70 miles you know so I
was watching the screen and you can see
kind of what the car is seen the lidar
system which is kind of laser radar to
understand how it's directly in itself
what percentage of your sales comes from
digital ordering now so we're over 60%
of our business now is digital order so
we are a digital company we're one of
the largest technology companies really
and what's the main way you can order a
pizza so you know people are mostly
doing it off of their iPhones off of
their Android phone on a dominant
leading orders they're the Domino's app
right you said there are 11 different
options there are different ways to
order a pizza or you can do it over
Amazon Alexa you can do it off of a
Google I mean all the different options
come on people here and act to the
quality of the pizza right you know I
mean do you believe that you have the
best pizza that you can find on the
planet we do but we are always looking
to make it better and so where do you go
to do that you go if you hear that is a
great pizza somewhere that little place
somewhere like New Jersey I eat a lot of
pizza Charlie I do a lot of personal
research but look our R&D I absolutely
do it I'm always Rises really I do good
for you it is absolutely you know what
you put a bunch of veggies on it it's a
terrific meal if you put on sausage and
pepperoni it's a little more salt yeah
it's great now have you heard this that
you guys are tracking this year to
surpass Pizza Hut which would make you
the number-one so at home in your living
room is there a Pizza Hut Pizza Hut box
with a target on it
I'm coming it's like that means you say
that about pizza we're definitely
getting there yeah
wasn't that a goal of yours when you
took this job it was oh is it always
gonna be pieces are with this kind of
remarkable penetration of a market you
can be at other kinds of things you know
what we're gonna sell one in seven
pizzas in the US tonight we're gonna
sell maybe one in 15 around the world
there is so much growth for us in pizza
we're gonna stick to what we do you
knitting huh
absolutely what's your favorite pizza
you know what I like a Pacific coast
veggie on thin crust or a hand pan
pepperoni so it's kind of indulgent to
pretty much the most popular pizza in
the country absolutely outstanding on a
thin crust Nora come on I know thank you
so much absolutely